hey
this program was recorded in 1982. what
were these men doing
they were making millions of dollars
selling ci terrorist equipment
expertise and actually training
libyans selling this equipment to libya
and actually training terrorists
in the libyan china lake terrorist
training camp
now as the story is is being squeezed
out in bits and pieces it's coming out
it's now been documented that there were
active duty special forces
officers uh helping them
to train terrorists inside libya now
we're talking about up until 78-79
and there were also ci active duty
personnel at china lake training
terrorists
and uh this even boggles my mind having
been inside and and from what i've seen
but all of the all of the to do we're
making about terrorism and here we are
deliver here our cia is delivering
technology and actually training libyan
terrorists
another fascinating evening with former
cia official john stockwell tonight on
alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
back in 1981 we did a program with john
stockwell called cia update
well it's no longer all that current but
well maybe it is
there are a lot of things that we talked
about in that program that you still
would be fascinated by so we're going to
see that again and present a new cia
story from 1986.
john stockwell is one of our good
friends and a firm fixture on
alternative views
i'm sure you know john by now he was a
former cia high official for 12 years
quit the cia and wrote very famous
informative book
in search of enemies well he's a
full-time writer now andy is on his
novel writing experience and one is just
coming out john what's the name of it
and what's it about well my second book
is red sunset it's a
story about some american oil company
people in a small african capital about
the woman principally
and the the adventures she gets into
which includes a chess match a love
story
a terrorist kidnap
attempt
which is the vehicle but really the
purpose of writing the book was to try
to discuss
what it's like our enemies our
detractors accuse us of being
imperialists and being involved in
neocolonialism
and it's always fascinated me because
i've lived the life that they call
neocolonialist of uh
in the in the big villa in a newly
independent country with several
servants and shiny new cars and jet
planes here and there while most of the
people in the country have very little
to survive to live off of
and so this is the story i i wanted to
write a story about ordinary americans
who live
that kind of a life and what what the
life is all about and how it affects the
people around them as well as themselves
and where does it take place what are
the actual scenes and characters and
actions i said it in burundi and i chose
burundi because it's very in africa
burundi is in i chose it because it's
exactly in the center of africa it's
it's as close to to nowhere so so to
speak as you can get it's also very
pretty place it's right on the western
rift valley right at the northern tip of
lake tanganyika and you have the mitumba
mountains and the varunga volcanoes and
the lake tanganyika and the city is
actually up overlooking the lake so it's
a gorgeous little place and and as i say
quite remote
well you grew up in africa well i grew
up in zaire which is right across the on
the other side of the lake and then i
served in zaire with the cia
these mitumba mountains that i write
about in this book were haven of rebels
when i was in zaire but i also served in
burundi at one time so we had problems
with uh
we the the mountains were sort of an
intelligence target so we were covering
them i was sending people into the
mountains and i became fascinated with
them in fact there were no viable
rebels there there was a great
exaggeration of the rebel threat because
that's a good way to keep the united
states and its aid interested in in
supporting your country
and i try to bring this out there was a
kidnapped
uh
threat
that was brought to us from people
across the lake who came into burundi
and said that they had information of a
plot to kidnap the american ambassador
and
this of course stirred us up no end as
you can imagine flash cables to
washington and on a full-time alert and
every security measure we could take
it turned out it was just a con
there was just some guys who wanted to
squeeze a little money a couple hundred
dollars out of us
but then i was there in in 1771 about
when i left
but in 75
these same people did kidnap four
european scholars
working with a caltech
grant who were studying fish or
something on the lake and they did
kidnap them and take them into the
mountains
and so naturally writing a novel about
that area i wanted to incorporate how
you know how a kidnap plot could work
and what kind of people would do it and
how it would affect the people in in the
city itself do you mostly focus on the
african political situation or the sort
of machinations between america and the
soviet union behind the scenes or do
both of these themes come out those
those themes are in the background i
wanted to focus on the life
of an american woman who finds herself
in such a place
and there is a soviet diplomat involved
there is she plays a big chess match
against the local chess master who's a
south african banker and some of their
friends are british
and the africans are in the background
their subplot sort of uh in the
background which some of the reviewers
have said is in a way and ironically the
strongest part of the book is the
africans in the background but i really
wanted the story to be about this young
woman not about politics or diplomacy so
much as just her life so there's an
element of the love story in that as
well as a political novel you're trying
to combine these themes it started out
to be more of a political intrigue novel
adventure intrigue
in real life politics
and what happened was the love story
took over the book
it was a subplot originally and then
by the time i got the the manuscript in
new york and sold it the editors wanted
me to focus on the woman and the love
story
and essentially they they persuaded me
and so
it is primarily a love story yes well
john you've been prohibited by the
courts now
to
say anything or write anything about the
cia and its operations
no no that's not exactly correct no
i can say all kinds of things about the
ci but i have to submit it to them for
censorship first so i assure you i could
write a hundred thousand page book about
the cia and as long as it was favorable
they wouldn't censor a word but you can
speak though
well impromptu speaking is covered
particularly if it's about the subject
of my previous book or what i've
lectured before they they admitted that
it would be very difficult to try to
enforce
an injunction against uh
interviews and and speeches
but if i had written notes for say this
interview
i would have to submit those notes for
censorship
well as long as it's impromptu though
i'm supposed to be okay we have a lot of
things here loaded up about the cia the
stories and information
that we've been gathering waiting for
your next trip over to alternative views
fortunately i haven't seen their notes
that they're going to be working from so
and they're not under injunctions they
don't have to be censored okay doug you
have probably the most important one
there well john to start off let's look
at the cia under the reagan
administration what are some of the most
significant occurrences
vis-a-vis the cia under reagan what has
he done in terms of his policies that
have affected the cia
well the the reagan
election when he came into office
there was
great joy in dancing in the halls of the
cia
they recognized that they would be set
back into
full
full-fledged activities
much like they were at the height of
their powers in the 50s and 60s
and and that euphoria has pretty much
continued
i have not been inside the building
obviously but i have had a couple of
conversations with people
uh who were and without telling me
anything of any substance they did their
voices were
were crowing and and gloating about how
the world was being righted in their
mind and they were out there defending
uh
national security and freedom in all
kinds of places as the ci has done in
chile and angola and nicaragua and
elsewhere for so many years they
announced on october the 1st that
they're going to literally double the
size of their new headquarters
the cia which would indicate that
they're obviously planning many more
activities and an expansion of their
entire operations what are some of the
evidence of an expanded cia
under reagan
well of course uh
you know i i was kidding i was up in
washington recently and i was getting so
many invitations
uh to go and lecture
that i was i was kidding and saying that
i had something that would go on forever
because i'm the last whistleblower
because they've got the court orders and
injunctions and
the supreme court rulings and now the
names of agents bill going through and
there won't be
all of which is to say that we probably
will never know for sure
what they're doing now under reagan
because they are succeeding in getting
in a de facto official secrets acts so
the the american public and the victims
will never know the true stories of
the current activities like the war in
angola
the pre-vietnam ci covert action
the chile coup the assassinations
they will be muzzled probably forever so
we won't know for sure
what you hear about
are the occasional it you know it's an
organization
that will always go around shooting
itself in the foot because it deals with
activists who are trained to to break
the law
who have activist instincts and they
will always be getting themselves in
trouble
and what we're really seeing now
are gross blunders and gross missteps
and one case where two
agents went so far a foul of propriety
in the law that it did erupt into the
public view that's turple and wilson
60 minutes and a pbs documentary those
are the ones who helped were helping
libya right incredible if if you can
believe it
look at the way our president is dealing
with the libyan problem and qaddafi our
country so concerned
with the terrorism
the hitman
[Music]
team that was supposed to be tracking
our president down to kill him
and now we find that two fairly senior
ci officers
were out actually training they had they
had resigned from the cia but they were
being supported by people who were at
the very top of the cia
who who it's not clear and of course
it may never come clear exactly to what
degree they were being supported but
they were being met debriefed and
assisted in some ways
by people like ted shackley who who is a
top ci he was chief of the latin america
division chief of the far east division
and then assistant deputy director of
operations now what were these men doing
they were making millions of dollars
selling ci terrorist equipment
expertise and actually training
libyans selling this equipment to libya
and actually training terrorists
in the libyan china lake terrorist
training camp
now as the story is is being squeezed
out in bits and pieces it's coming out
it's now been documented that there were
active duty special forces
officers uh helping them
to train terrorists inside libya now
we're talking about up until 78-79
and there were also ci active duty
personnel at china lake training
terrorists
and uh this even boggles my mind having
been inside and and from what i've seen
but all of the all of the to do we're
making about terrorism and here we are
deliver here our cia is delivering
technology and actually training libyan
terrorists this sort of illustrates your
thesis
in a search for enemies that the
function of the cia is to cause problems
that makes it possible for military
intervention so that would fit into this
sort of scenario that you've drawn
indeed and there's no other real
explanation for it now one
one of the ci officers who
was still in the cia
uh he denied at first association with
him they were claiming that he had
supported him he denied it
and
then when it when it was when he had to
admit or perjure himself he had to admit
that there was
association
he he claimed that it was only to keep
contact so they could tell him what the
terror who the terrorists were and what
they were doing therefore it was a legit
legitimate ci enterprise
but then when when the senate tried to
squeeze out and the justice department
documentation from the cia there was
none
and he said that was because it was
something that he was keeping in his
vest pocket
so either we have a full-fledged ci
operation or we have an illegal
venal corrupt operation but either way
there was complicity with these people
who were training
and and making the libyan terrorists a
great deal more more effective now mind
you we're talking about millions of
dollars we're talking about the the
latest and terrorist you know explosive
devices and and the way you can make an
ashtray into an explosive device so when
a bad guy puts out his or a good guy for
that matter puts out his cigar it blows
up and kills everyone in the room you
know this sort of thing well isn't there
this seems even more incredible from a
couple points of view one is the fact
that maybe it's a super machiavellian
thing that the cia and the fbi need to
have terrorists in the world to justify
their increased
money for appropriations for instance
when the cia made their latest report
they indicated that there were 3336
terrorist attacks during the previous
year now alexander haig didn't think
that was enough so he sent the report
back to the cia say give me more
terrorist attacks so they they upped it
to almost 6 000.
this
then then the other aspect of this
is that the ci has historically had a
close relationship with the israeli
secret police the mossad
and yet the mossad
and the
libyan government and their secret
police were mortal enemies supposedly
so what's going on here
well on the one hand the cia purist
would argue that we have an intelligence
requirement to provide information to
our government about terrorists
and terrorist organizations about the
world and therefore the only way you can
get this information is to penetrate
terrorist organizations
get your people inside so they can tell
you what's being done
the other side of that is is very much
in the direct and on the first argument
you would you would try to have contact
with mossad and with the libyans and
with the plo and with the red brigade
anyone you could and the kgb and the kgb
uh to gather information about them
that's the purest
purest argument but how can you explain
this provision of
of of shiploads of terrorist equipment
to the libyans and training by active
duty special forces
and active duty ci officers
now that's that's where it gets so
machiavelli and it blows your mind and
there's no way you can justify
delivering the equipment to them in
order to gather information about who
they are that's not necessary to gather
intelligence and the only answer is that
a little bit of both that you have an
organization that functions in a
troubled world it gets more money and
more
opportunity as like you say hague wants
6 000 terrorist bombings last year not
three thousand because it's more
dramatic and he can get more mileage out
of it the cia by the same token would
like to have a more troubled world
because there they have more to do the
president the congress and the press and
everybody are are relying on them and
giving them their carte blanche more in
a troubled world than in a peaceful
world
uh but then the other thing that has
raised its head
not the first time but but
so ominously in this wilson turple thing
is is individuals doing it for gain
for millions of bucks let's face it
someone in the ci who's commanded wars
around the world
uh
sent people off to die which you know
which is the ultimate ego trip for a
pentagon type of person is the ultimate
power that a human being can have is to
send other humans off to die
not sentence one individual to the gas
chamber but send five thousand off to
die but take someone who's been at the
top of the ci and he's been doing this
secretly and and
commanding forces in the world
manipulating governments and then he
hits a certain age of maybe 50 or
possibly 60 if he goes the whole route
and then he retires on 20 000 a year
and it just you know it just isn't
comfortable it doesn't work now some of
these people
have managed to to retire comfortably
like bill colby the former director and
uh dick helms former director by
becoming agents of foreign governments
and so declaring themselves
to our our justice department and
getting a salary from the iranian
government or the japanese government or
elsewhere and people down the line have
done the same sort of thing and walters
is now
getting hundreds of thousands of dollars
consulting for guatemala argentina chile
et cetera and vernon walters was who the
deputy director of the cia when i was in
he was the deputy director over me and
was nixon's white house man too
so selling themselves as agents of
foreign governments to sell their
expertise and contacts that they
gathered in their ci careers and then
you have these guys it's now surfaced
and it's it's an obvious it's a
documented fact have been selling
uh technology terrorist technology to
the libyan government
meanwhile our government is not moving
against the vernon walters or the dick
helmses or the bill colbys
who have become agents of foreign
governments
but they're suing john stockwell for
writing a book to the american people to
tell the truth about what's going on and
they're trying to pass a bill that would
make it illegal for
any publication to publish the names of
any cia agents how does this constitute
a threat to freedom of the press mind
you this bill is it's justified on the
basis of the revelation of names
but the bill goes far far beyond names
it says names of secret agents or the
activities of secret agents that could
draw attention to them
now this means for example let's take
some things that the cia has done
a secret agent
kicks in your door
and rapes your wife
now if you went out and wrote an article
about that and published it in the paper
both you and the editors of the paper
even if you didn't name them you just
said mr x working for the ci kicked in
my door last night and raped my wife
that would be a felony under this law
and the debate in congress on this law
some of the critics and there are some
fortunately but not enough
said wait a minute the way this thing
the way i read this proposed bill
if the london times published an article
about a ci escapade somewhere
the new york times could not reprint the
london times article without committing
a felony
and the sponsors of the bill stood up
and roared that is right we want to stop
all of this
talk about the cia
so what we have here
by the sponsor's own admission is an
official secrets act and a very strict
one one that will cover anything they
want to cover up they classify it
and claim it has to do with secret
agents activities my book can never be
published
the the cbs and pbs
stories that you mentioned on on turple
and wilson could not be published it
would be a felony
many of the 60-minute shows would be
felonies so this provides a cover of
secrecy for the cia of the broadest
possible sort for the first time in our
history freedom of speech has been
is being now it hasn't passed yet
although the knows count is that it will
go sliding right through congress right
now but for the first time in our
history
the secret police of the government are
being given
legal precedent over freedom of speech
and freedom of the press
now mind you they've bludgeoned people
before and punished people before
such as myself and frank snep and and
philadelphi for for attacking for
criticizing the the cia
but they've done that in civil court but
now it will be a felony to criticize the
ci to complain about its activities to
expose its corruption
and and the record is clear we're
talking about an organization
that has been responsible for
three hundred thousand deaths by their
own records by the the senate's own
records three hundred thousand deaths in
in the third world
uh and that's that's a modest figure i
gave that figure myself in senate
testimony and the next morning sai
hirsch
uh
i was playing tennis with him and he he
he said stock well you're all wet he
said the figures over 500 000 you forgot
indonesia
now
that's what they've been doing out in
the world of course in the mood of these
times there are a lot of americans who
who would just assume melt africa or
asia or wherever they really could care
less but they have been doing things in
the united states that you would you
know
strange-loving kind of things that you
would only accredit to the gestapo or
the kgb at their worst
drug
mk ultra extensive over years
experimenting with unwitting americans
by by dropping them lsd and then filming
their activities under the influence of
drugs they didn't know they had received
as well as infiltrating political groups
and spying on americans which were
against the cia charter it was not
supposed to be domestically involved and
carter put some guidelines regulating
domestic activity of the cia and reagan
assigned an executive order putting
these aside putting these aside in
effect unleashing the cia domestically
so that any political group can be or
any individual could be the target of a
cia operation so this is a another
threat to our civil liberties here in
the country for sure and they're
defining who the targets are they don't
have to even go to a judge
and say we think this person's a target
they decide who a target is and secrecy
as i've said before and and many other
people have said
including some some
leading senators secrecy is primarily
designed to cover up their misdeeds
only in in the very rare most internal
sensitive cases
is secrecy a matter of national security
yes diplomacy at a certain point you
need some secrecy to negotiate some
things at a certain point some military
operations have to be secret to work
but you know we're talking about a tenth
of a percent as compared to everything
that is in fact uh being declared secret
what they're trying to cover up is the
wars the killings the drug
experimentation and the corruption
there's another bizarre development that
seems to be taking place with the cia
under the reagan administration that i
think involves a tremendous expansion of
cia operations and a sort of new field
for the cia to get involved in and
that's the use of businessmen and the
department of commerce as potential
agents when the max hugel affair took
place early in the reagan administration
where this corrupt politician
businessman friend of reagan's was put
in a position of high power in the cia
and it turns out that he had all kinds
of corrupt business backgrounds and
connections
it came out on abc's nightline the ted
koppel show in an interview with bobby
inman who's deputy director of the cia
that the reason max hugo was brought
into the white house was that he had a
lot of businessmen connections that they
would be able to use for operations
abroad
what do you make of this is this a
significantly new
field for the cia to be involved in we
know that they've used politicians and
diplomats abroad they've used military
abroad they've even used journalists
that's been revealed well it's by no
means new but but we're talking about a
degree they've done it many many times
and they've done favors for people all
over the world gathering information for
them you know a little favor yes we'll
find out this for you what not but it's
a question of degree and in in the last
few years including before i got out
there was the government the us
government was crying for more economic
information and during a lot of the
years that i was in we were not you know
we would get an economic information and
pass it on to the ambassador to stop him
in the hall and say hey i heard such and
so a deal is going down or something but
what's happening now
is your microphone yes my microphone is
falling off the cia arrangement i'm sure
what's happening now is the this
corruption that i'm talking about where
a political party
a white house administration is salting
people into top positions in the agency
because of their business connections
with the intent
of using the organization and its
resources to gather intelligence to help
the people who are sponsoring that party
this is of course the heaviest form of
corruption that position that hugo was
in was deputy director of operations now
this is the focal point the commanding
officer of worldwide clandestine
operations now you think of the
sensitivity and the complexity
of covert operations in 150 countries
and
this is a job
that has to be a pro and a brilliant pro
and one with driving energy
uh
in any sense of the word now mind you i
i think that we would probably be better
off if the job didn't exist
but but there's no way it can function
with a political appointee in there and
as a matter of fact there was the uh
part of the reason he was withdrawn was
because uh
he was shooting himself in the foot
repeatedly several times there was an
incident about
libya and he was you know in this effort
to get the cia moving again he was
approving some some exceedingly
dangerous operations assassinating
gaddafi according to a newsweek he was
proposing to assassinate qaddafi and
there to my relief now the senate
supervisory the oversight committee
which has never succeeded in overseeing
the ci room never tried very much mostly
they're encouraging them to go out and
do they did scream at that one and stop
him and it was shortly thereafter that
hugo was was removed from office now we
have the other one at the top william
casey is another businessman with all
kinds of conflicts of interest he's
still holding the portfolio on his own
business interest plus all of his
contacts
and he's running the whole intelligence
organization right now
and he again like the other one he's
shooting himself in the foot about once
a week
and late
lately two days ago he testified to the
senate and about the freedom of
information operation
and
he was
claiming that the cia couldn't function
because they had they had so many agents
wouldn't work with us but also so many
people resigned because of this
foia
and when the committee of course didn't
just take his word for it they said give
us documentation
and he couldn't produce any
documentation and finally he had to
admit that not one person had been fired
because of or resigned because of the
foia
so once again
john you were talking about complexity
and the byzantine nature of some of the
operations that go on in the
in the cia here's one really
mind-blowing thing which was in the
august 81 inquiry the libertarian
magazine
it talks about
an incredible thing it talks about first
of all a florida-based worldwide finance
corporation that's that's its name
it's a financial conglomerate
and after there were some complaints
that led to the doorstep of this thing
a local district attorney started
investigating it
there were congressional investigations
and the justice department started
getting into it and they found that
cia was involved cuban exiles were
involved which isn't really all that
unusual because they've been involved
for
decades down there in the miami area
and their operations against fidelity
assassination of a president right
but this also gets involved with drug
trafficking
and even further than that they've found
that there are relationships with the
russian kgb and the cia operating
together exchanging information they
found that there is there have been
relationships with castro's intelligence
and the cia in which the cia and castro
decided that they would permit the drug
trafficking and helping it along
and then share the help and sharing and
the profits so they could uh
so they could finance each other's
operations
and
it
the investigations
well they kind of it became so complex
that the investigations not only kind of
collapsed because they couldn't figure
out what the heck was happening they
couldn't unravel it
but also the cia stepped in and put the
kibosh on it
and even the fbi was frustrated because
they were involved in a two
this seems
like something which you couldn't even
dream up if you had a wild imagination
we're on some kind of drug trip does
this sound unreasonable no
you know like real life is often
stranger than fiction and uh i've i've
already run into this in the
the three books that i've written with
uh
trying to write scenes as exactly as
they
happened and then your editors scream at
you and you say but but i was there and
that's exactly the way it happened and
they they finally say well nobody would
believe it in france
but yes i'm i'm quite sure that's
that could happen
i don't know anything about that
organization i haven't followed it but
all of that could easily happen well the
one part of it really sounds true and
that's the
permission and expediting of the
narcotic traffic for the cuban exile so
that they can help finance their
operations this sounds very much like
what was going on in vietnam southeast
asia sounds like a dream business to get
into because you would be able to do
favors for the cia the fbi
the kgb
the anti-castro
groups in florida
and
the ann castro himself and the drug
runners
so you would have all of these
organizations paying you off
and giving you protection
and that sounds like if you were if you
were into corruption in crime it would
be a dream organization well there was
drug trafficking by the cia and during
the vietnam war yes that's been
documented uh
and the book has been written politics
of heroin in southeast asia with with uh
documents i mean documented with
government documents they got that
conclusively proved and stated that the
cia
was
the way it started is they were working
with mountain yards who had up in
thailand mostly but also in laos
cambodia and vietnam who had made their
living traditionally by growing heroin
and shipping it out and
so they had the ci had its air forces
flying planes back and forth
and the montana allies would be flying
down to the capitol
and they would want to get on the planes
of these suitcases full of heroin
and the ci you know some ci officers
were trying to kick them off but you
know these were your allies you needed
them so the ci was making decisions to
let them ride
and then it got to the point where
uh and by that i'm making making
decisions up the chain of command then
it got to the point where they were
actually flying special flights dc3
flights to carry the heroin down to the
capital as favors for the allies and
also to sort of help finance the whole
operation and then it got to the point
where of course some of the cia officers
involved were finding ways to use ci
vehicles to fly the stuff back to the
states and market it that's documented
the last leg of that
was not to my knowledge approved by
washington that was that was the
maverick but the rest of it was approved
by washington there's another surprising
story that came out in the latest covert
action information bulletin and that is
that shortly before his death anwar
sadat admitted that egypt was the
conduit for cia funds
to create problems in afghanistan to aid
the rebels so that the united states was
involved early on in the reagan
administration with actually uh
fostering the afghan rebellion have you
heard any stories of this nature only
what i've read in the press
and
you know this gets this to me gets into
some of the ultimate
cynicism at the same time one of the
more complex decisions
of people in the intelligence world
is you have the soviets in afghanistan
and it's our national politic policy to
regret their presence there
you have rebels who are fighting them
and obviously if they had more arms they
would fight better
but there isn't any chance
of our giving them enough support that
they could win or even get some momentum
going against the soviets
so we trickle some arms into them so
they can escalate the flight the
fighting
with the result that a lot more people
are killed and their hopes are raised
and they think they're
in some cases they're flat told of
course the worst case in history of this
being done was where the cia had a huge
program to encourage
the hungarian uprising and they
succeeded the country erupted in a
massive uprising and then when the
soviets put their tanks in the united
states jumped you know
back across the ocean and got our hands
off the place and the hungarians twenty
thousand hungarians died what happened
with the kurds yeah it happened it
occurred
it occurred in iran yes many thousands
of kurds died identical when we had
satisfied the shah's little
pressure policy initiative against iraq
and the shah said okay i've got my
agreement with iraq we jumped back and
withdrew our aid from the kurds and the
iraqis retaliated and wiped them out
there's also a report here about
biological warfare in cuba that certain
mosquitoes were introduced to cubans
claimed by the c.i.a that resulted in
fever malaria of all sorts have you
heard anything about that story yes the
dinghy fever i've certainly heard about
it i've seen written stories about it
i've talked to people about it
the the us health the u.s medical
authority's line is that it's not
technically possible to introduce
fever or fever-ridden mosquitoes into
cuba which is of course nonsense
the difficult thing about that is that
there's an epidemic of fever in cuba the
cubans claim the ci was behind it
if the cubans could be making it up they
could believe it and be saying it
or it could be completely true
the point though is that our government
rci has been guilty of so many things
just as nasty as that over the past 30
years
that it's absolutely impossible to to
deny it
plus the fact that they carried out
experiments just on this type of thing
they released
millions of mosquitoes over at
charleston south carolina to
just to observe what would happen
and then apparently it's possible when
they
put this into effect in cuba although it
then i understand their main
their main target would have been for
the soviet union well they're preparing
for the biological warfare wherever
you know in our concern with nuclear
warfare and i am very concerned
all these atom bombs that we have and
they have and the macho people some of
them not very bright
uh beating themselves on you know the
chest and and talking but the chemical
and biological bombs that are being
amassed
may be a hundred times as lethal and
dangerous and threatening to life on the
on on earth
than than the nuclear bombs well the
nazis force saw this rather than put
their technology into a nuclear atomic
bomb program they had these chemical
warfare you remember the ci had uh
had been it had been revealed that they
had some poison they were and and the
president nixon had ordered them to get
rid of it right and then they didn't get
rid of it and pres and director colby
was called up to explain why they hadn't
obeyed a specific
presidential order
and with his incredible talent for
disarming the senate he said after all
gentlemen we're not talking about a big
warehouse he said we're talking about
something this size and he held up a
little vial it was enough poison to kill
everyone in a city of fifty thousand he
held up a little vial this big he said
it was sitting in the back of a safe
and you know when you think about that
and when you think that there are
warehouses of that poison alone
not to mention the disease and germs and
things that can blow this way and that
uh the work
and there isn't the publicity of the
public attention on the the abc
arsenals that are being stockpiled
john another event we wanted you to
comment on since this is part of your
past experience in south africa or
angola has to do with the invasion by
south african troops in angola on the
pretext that angola is supporting
nanibian rebels and that south africa
has to clean up the operations there and
there's soviet and cuban troops there
they're a threat to south africa would
you comment on that what's the current
status has south africa been continuing
to harass and go several months back we
reported in detail
it's my understanding that south africa
has sort of a permanent
military force inside angola i don't
mean they've
built camps but they are there
bombing raiding dropping people in
uh uh
on on a permanent basis regularly
several hundred miles up inside angola
what you have in terms of the validity
of their claims
you know africa was was when it was
broken into colonies that became
countries they were done without any
reference whatsoever to the the the tr
the existing tribes or ethnic groupings
so that in angola for example you have
on the north you have the bakongo as a
large original tribe that now overlaps
in three countries
and uh in the north uh east you have the
balunda who who overlap angola and into
zaire and in the south you have the
people who are the namibians are are the
the people who are
of the ethnic grouping with the people
in southwest africa but half of the
people live inside angola
now
it goes without saying that these people
with their ethnic link to those people
are going to be sympathetic and there's
going to be support and is going to be
traveling back and forth across the
border
but what you get into is of course the
modern
law what is south africa's right to go
up and and bomb and strafe south
africa's position of course is is
it's an outlaw position on southwest
africa they're simply refusing to to
give it
its own freedom its own elections which
was mandated by the united nations a
long years ago and they just absolutely
refused to cooperate with this and and
to date no no pressure has been brought
on them that would really encourage them
to
to set namibia free to give it its free
election is there any evidence of cia
complicity in this frank wanted to ask
about the seychelles island some of
these might be connected
well the there was a coup attempt
of the seychelles islands
in which
a
rugby team
supposedly rugby team
came into
the social islands into the airport
there are also some people that were
that came in earlier in hotels and they
tried to
overthrow the government they had
weapons with them
and later it was determined
that they their base of operations was
south africa matter of fact they took
over an airplane and returned to south
africa
from what you're reading of this is is
there was there cia complicity and money
involved in that or are the south
africans just becoming like a new cia
and doing their own mischief
well it also connected and in all
in all fairness and to state the obvious
the cia is not the only agent of
mischief in the world
and
there are many other agents of mischief
the ci is working with many of the
others as they do
as they commit their crimes
i
have as far as is there any
documentation i wouldn't have the
faintest idea all i know is what i've
read in the papers
so you have to speculate they obviously
had
at least an atmosphere of encouragement
in south africa including in the south
african government
when they they uh
skyjacked the plane and flew back to
south africa five of them were arrested
and the rest would just turn free
immediately and these five
were flown off in a helicopter to
someone's estate after posting a minimal
bond
then because of international pressure
south africa did go back and arrest 30
more
it's not clear yet what they're going to
succeed in and what they're going to try
them for
or or or if they will in fact convict
them
but
i i could easily see something like that
as more likely developing from south
africans with their very aggressive
attitude towards the seychelles
possibly with ci4 knowledge but quite
possibly without the cia knowing about
it ahead of time
had the ci known about it ahead of time
i'm i'm reasonably sure they would not
have complained or protested that
wouldn't be in their nature
but i see no reason to to to suggest
that they set it up on the other hand
it's quite possible it's the sort of
thing that the cia station chief might
very well do
having dinner going to the office of
the boss chief i think they call it
something else now the south african
security force and saying you know what
you know you big talk what are you going
to do about the seychelles why don't you
fly some people up there and take the
place and turn it in the right direction
and then the the south african calling
in a couple of
rugby players or former mercenaries and
saying you know it would be easy here's
what you would have to do
and giving them some advice and guiding
and setting it in motion maybe some
money
i might note to our audience it is quite
remarkable that john stockwell in the
last few years has begun his second
career as a novelist as you might know
it's very difficult to get a book
published much less a novel these days
and john's first novel was immediately
picked up by william moore which is one
of the best new york publishers and has
just come out so we congratulate you
john on your new career and wish you all
the best but we still want you to come
back and talk to us about the cia and
many other things on alternative views
remember i'm the last whistleblower
i'll never be i'll never be dated
thank you john thank you thank you very
much
since we videotaped our interview with
john stockwell in recent cia activities
a conference has taken place in the
boston area on reviving the cia over a
10-day period more than a thousand
people attended and quite a few scholars
and anti-cia activists provided an
update on cia activity there were two
reports in that conference that we
didn't touch on in our discussion with
john first of all saul landau of the
institute for policy studies in
washington d.c
reported that he had information that
the reagan administration had notified
congress in mid-december that the cia
was coordinating border raids from
honduras into nicaragua and was also
using a clandestine radio station to
send false rumors to the mosquito
indians in eastern nicaragua the
sandinistas intended to exterminate them
in an attempt to get these indians to
have an uprising against the nicaraguan
government there was also a report in
the conference by a vietnamese scholar
novin long that during the
cia operations in vietnam they recruited
agents who are still active in vietnam
carrying on cia operations against the
vietnamese people and also indicated
that certain right wing vietnamese are
now being paid by the cia to spy on the
vietnamese who have come to settle in
this country and that in some cases
certain of these right-wing vietnamese
have taken retaliatory actions against
left-wing members of the vietnamese
community living in america indicating
that there are still vietnamese
intelligence agents and politics going
on in this country
now we jump from nineteen eighty one to
nineteen eighty six
well well well guess what
it looks like old danny loft might have
been doing some business with the c.i.a
after all of course not admitted until
he got back into the united states and
then not even publicized much in
by the regular media
but it seems that two days after donnie
loft left the soviet union the u.s
officials changed their story about his
contacts with the cia back in 1985 so it
raises some questions about how innocent
the man was
maybe he was was innocent but maybe he
was just used well we'll see
donaloff confirmed some of these
allegations himself at an october 13th
issue of news u.s news and world report
where he said he was approached by a
father roman who is a
who was supposedly a priest and he was
sought out by him and was given some
information well long island newspaper
newsday correspondent roy goodman made
an investigation into this
and he reported that this father roman
promised to give daniel danilov
some material on religious subjects
and he asked danilov to
take the material to the u.s embassy
which then elof did
but there were some other envelopes
including one addressed to cia director
william casey and that was given to the
cia station chief all from this one
package from father roman
now in one letter was a reference to
rockets and other military subjects
according to
the newsday washington reporter
and
one embassy asked danilov how to get in
touch with roman and he provided
information on how to do it so in a very
unusual move and what administration
officials was very amateurish a c i a
man actually called this father rahman
on the phone
and said yeah we got the packet and then
he later said remind a note
saying that
he had received the package from the
journalist's friend just re just
confirming his telephone conversation
so
as a result of all these events the u.s
was eager to have deleted off
freed
because of the cia mishandling of this
whole business
so
it's a question whether danilov was
really involved himself or whether he
was just inadvertently used but
nonetheless
well
what's the final
analysis helen ellen ray who
contributes a lot to the covert action
information bolton and is the
co-director of the institute for media
analysis said
in answer the question was
danny love spying he said well he admits
to delivering documents to the embassy
discussing them with cia agents and
giving them information about the man
who gave them to him
which the cia then used to contact the
man
and she said you don't have to be on the
cia's payroll to commit espionage
and it might at least have led the
soviet union to believe that denial off
was a spy
and who knows maybe the guy was a setup
by the kgb right and indeed a faction in
the kgb that was opposed to gorbachev
summit with the u.s this is all lost in
murky u.s soviet relations but what's
most striking to me about the danilov
zakharov affair is that the u.s media
almost unanimously assumed that danilov
was an innocent journalist who is either
set up by the c.i.a or a victim of ci of
rather kgb repression whereas zakarov
was supposedly a soviet spy who was
caught red-handed and was guilty without
any question at all well an article in
october first in these times raises some
question about this and indicates that
the zakarov case has all the earmarks of
an fbi sting parallel to the abscam case
where the fbi stung certain congressmen
by tempting them with certain lucrative
payoffs from different supposed arabs
who are really fbi agents in disguise
well to put the zacharov case in
perspective in these times argues you
have to go back to the early days of the
reagan administration when gene
kirkpatrick was the head of the u.s
delegation to the united nations and was
claiming that the u.n was a hotbed of
third world radicalism and that the u.n
was a nest of soviet spies the problem
was that gene kirkpatrick didn't have
any evidence that any soviet
u.n officials were actually engaged in
espionage for the soviet union and were
therefore looking very closely at the
soviet u.n employees to see if they
could find some evidence of any kind of
spine for the soviet union whatsoever
the story then jumps to 1983
when a computer major at queen's college
got a call from a u.n official asking
him if he would do some work accessing
some data networks for him to get some
information on technology and military
affairs
the computer
major john had put up an advertisement
saying that he was willing to do
database searches for people and
zacharov had seen the advertisement and
contacted him and then supposedly john
went to the fbi and said that
he was approached by a soviet agent or
soviet u.n official who was going to ask
him to do some computer searches and
from there after the fbi was monitoring
this situation very closely what
zacharov was doing at this time from
1983 to 1985 was perfectly legal he was
at that time in the un center for
science and technology where he was
responsible for collecting and
appraising information on scientific
developments to give to third world
countries so it was logical that he
would look for some database searches in
18 in 1985 however john was given a job
with a
queen's firm that was engaged in
manufacture of unclassified precision
parts for military equipment it was
suggested in this in these times article
that john might have been given this job
to try to set up zakarov to tempt him
with some military information and thus
be able to arrest him as a spy and now
it's not clear who to believe zakarov
admitted that he worked with john for a
couple years
and said that he continued to get
information from john from this military
company that he worked for in queens but
claimed that this was all unclassified
data john however and the fbi confirms
this claims that
zacharov offered to do a 10-year
contract with john to pay him for
unclassified military information and it
was at this point that he was arrested
and was accused of being a spy and then
of course a week later or shortly
thereafter the soviets pinched danella
in any case the question is why would
the u.s arrest than zakharov in any case
since he there was no information that
he had anything that was of value any
military secrets and this became a major
media blitz against the soviet union and
imperiled the summit the hypothesis of
the in these times reporter is that
there might have been people in the
reagan administration who are trying to
sabotage the summit between ray and
gorbachev and this was one way to do it
it might have been even more complex
than that i think it was in the nation
i forgot to bring that article with me
but there was a
a reporter analysis of it speculating on
perhaps it might have been
the danilov affair set up by the kgb
or the military industrial complex of
the of the soviet union itself because
we know the soviet union is not a
monolith and there are hawks in the
within the pulley bureau and
etcetera
who would not like to see all these
great reductions and armaments that
that
the
secretary is wanting to
to offer
so it could be that they
set up uh danilov knowing that the
united states would take the bait and
create a lot of hate and discontent and
then they wouldn't be able to get this
agreement and so the hawks in the soviet
union one as well as in the united
states right and what's striking is the
way that the media in the united states
just presumed that the noaa was innocent
and zakharov was guilty and didn't do
any in-depth investigation of either of
these fellows or they didn't release any
of the information that quest
that cast shadows on the official report
in the left-wing newspapers you didn't
see any of this in time newsweek the
networks or any of the major newspapers
that's why you got to read the
alternative press in order to find out
what's happening
that's alternative views for this
evening we'd like to thank austin
community television ac tv for the use
of their equipment
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network
po box 7279 austin texas 78713